after the pension reform
time for institutional reform
and for the occasion
emmanuel macron wants to see things big
with a possible return to the septena
and a new territorial organization
in private the president declares
that we need to restore popular sovereignty
and adds that it is necessary to give oneself the ambition to
do something big
otherwise I am not for it
concretely what he has in mind
emmanuel macron would have the idea of returning to septena
with the implementation of a legislative election in mid
mandate a bit like the meettums in the United States
in all cases
the president would like to desynchronize
legislative elections
of the presidential election
in addition to establishing the proportional
whether it's the full proportional
or a dose of
this one
was one of his promises in two thousand ten seven
and he still hasn't given it up
to reduce the number of parliamentarians
and the president would also like to return to the name
accumulation of mandates
to allow the mayor of small communities to be
also Member of Parliament
another project of this reform of institutions
a new territorial organization
with perhaps the removal of the regional level
because emmanuel macron wants only two levels
administrative activities over the heads of people
the new status of
currently in negotiations
could be integrated into this reform
in all cases
an herbal tea transport commission will be put in place
place in spring
emmanuel macron has already started the consultations
by talking to his two predecessors
french hollande and nicolas sarkozy
and with
the presidents of both houses of parliament
yel bran pivet and gérard larcher